now it's Justin's turn in Virginia hi
Justin how are you I'm doing great Dave
how are you better than I deserve sir
how can I help ya so my wife and I we
started financial constructs months ago
currently in baby step two already paid
down thirteen thousand dollars in debt
way to go and now we're on track to be
debt-free in about 20 months good so my
question for you is this I'm at work a
pastor at a church and after speaking to
our CPA he was educating us on how I can
go exempt and to paying Social Security
exactly I haven't heard you talk about
this but one I was curious that that's
something you would recommend me do and
if yes should I take that money put it
towards our debt snowball and then
eventually roll that into like a Roth
IRA yes now let's walk through some
specifics okay okay
number one the exemption when you're a
pastor on Social Security is only your
pastoral income if you have a side
hustle you're still paying Social okay
okay so it's only when the church pays
you that's it that's the only thing that
gets exempt now once you do that and
let's say that that over the course of
your life is most of or all of your
income so on that basis you would have
no Social Security right okay now
mathematically were you to actually
invest the money that you put into
Social Security and you were to lose 1%
per year you would still have more money
than the government's gonna give you
right that's how bad it sucks yep
okay and that's what I would the rate of
return for Social Security yeah it's a
negative 1 to negative 2 percent right
of return right and so but if you're not
going to have Social Security we have to
think about what it does and you have to
make sure you do what it does with that
money and other money so first thing is
you're going to get a supplement to
retirement which is what Social Security
is it's not a replacement for retirement
it's a supplement so you have to be
investing
for retirement so it's like raise your
right hand say I promise to invest for a
retirement because I'm not going to have
any if I don't and you do that right
then the second thing is if you become
disabled completely disabled you would
receive SSI if you were in Social
Security you're not in it you won't get
that and our kids won't get anything if
you become disabled or die and so those
are the two those are the three things
you need life insurance to make sure
your family is okay you need long-term
disability insurance and you need two
retirement plan guess what you need all
of those anyway right everyone does
Social Security is not good enough for
any of those things right so but you
cannot ignore those three areas and get
caught in a lurch if you're gonna that
would be irresponsible right okay and so
what we're doing is we're giving up a
socialized bad math horrible program in
return we have more of our own money to
keep but we have to take care of
ourselves right that's that's the that's
the onus of the thing which is
retirement disability and life insurance
for your family those are the three
things you've got always no matter what
no exceptions have those three things in
place always no matter what no
exceptions the last piece of the
equation is the only way that you can
opt out under the IRS Code is you have
to as a pastor conscientiously object on
a religious basis to the Social Security
system and that's a matter of conscience
now if I were a pastor the Bible that I
read says we're supposed to be good
stewards good managers of God's money
giving it to Social Security is under no
definition being a good steward so I can
opt out on religious regions of good
conscience for I in your shoes but you
need to ask yourself that question do
you agree with that and if you do then
you in good conscience can become a
conscientious objector to the system and
not play on your pastoral income only
I definitely would but mathematically
it's smart spiritually it's correct
biblically it's correct people disagree
with me on that so I always just want to
be real clear on you decide you know
based on those parameters that critical
thinking said okay right and thank you
so much hey man thanks for the call
appreciate you serving God